la star de la cuisine certaine c'est
maïté chaque mardi 12h15 elle donne
rendez vous aux aquitains et depuis
quelques jours aux belges au canadien
bref au pays de langue française
desservie par satellite par tv5
maïté connu internationalement c'est
fait depuis le 2 avril
et bien cette landaise de pure souche
est en cuisine depuis peu son métier
c'était annonceurs à la sncf à métier
dure fatigante sur les voies ferrées
hiver tu mettais des heures durant son
rôle avertir les ouvriers travaillant
sur la voie de l'arrivée du train j'ai
ça 22 ans
22h je partais le matin jusqu'au soir
avec mon mari emporté
voilà toute la journée on a fait j'ai
fait les chantiers depuis il joue sous
plus loin jusqu'à puyo et de presque
bayonne dax et hossa en fait tout le
parcours sur les plombs et le chantier
retraité de la sncf ce maïs et a trouvé
sa véritable vocation la cuisine depuis
six mois elle est gérante d'un
restaurant sur sa carte caille farcie au
foie gras pigeon flambé à l'armagnac
poules farcies ou faisant au sauternes
des saveurs bien gasconne très loin de
la nouvelle cuisine toute la bande de
cuisine danse mijotés et la nouvelle
cuisine qu'est ce que vous en pensez
maintenant c'est une horreur c'est une
horreur ce même hauteur
parce que ça couvre toute la cuisine on
voit des choses ses services dans des
grandes assiettes ça ne va quand même
pas la précaution de le placer over unis
rien c'est 7 à feu ou sortez les vois
que vous décorer sa fait de la colère
c'est du rouge du vert du jaune du blanc
c'est très joli mais ça n'a aucun bon
cet affreux la cuisine des mousquetaires
c'est une émission qui fait un malheur
des milliers de lettres
huit mille recettes communiquées l'année
dernière alors entre la trompette de la
sncf et les fourneaux maïté a trouvé son
bonheur régalé les gourmands se par sa
petite pratiquement dans le monde entier
je me suis laissé dire et puis ça a un
certain succès alors j'en suis quand
même fier et quand même